il bisogno di raccontare
è un tratto distintivo
ed essenziale dell'umanità dalla notte
dei tempi
raccontare storie è un modo che gli
esseri umani
utilizzano per comprendere il mondo per
storie ci permettono di riflettere su
noi stessi per conoscerci e distinguersi
dagli altri di muoverci tra passato e
futuro
come ha detto lo scrittore e
sceneggiatore robert mackey la storia
non è una fuga dalla realtà da un
veicolo che ci conduce nella nostra
ricerca della realtà
ed è per questo che per me ha un valore
inestimabile
come per tante persone
l'attuale scienza è stato il momento in
cui ho cominciato ad appassionarmi alle
storie poi sulla carta e sui libri e
anch'io come tutte le ragazzine
dell'epoca quando guardavo un film o una
serie tv mi identificavo con l'eroina no
non quella che ti manda in ospedale per
overdose l'altra eroina la protagonista
della storia
il problema però è che non solo
quell'eroina non aveva neanche vagamente
un corpo simile al mio
ma la sua vita non ci prova proprio
niente con la mia
eppure io rimanevo ugualmente
affascinata l'idea di vedere qualcuno
come me sullo schermo non mi passava
neanche per l'anticamera del cervello
anzi io desideravo essere proprio come
quelle eroina e donne con corpi sinuosi
e super fascinose che si innamoravano
gli uomini altrettanto false losi e che
vivevano felici per sempre quello che
poi la mia mente anni e anni dopo
inserirà automaticamente per genere
fantascienza
insomma mentre io cercavo
invano briciole di me stessa in quelle
storie l'assenza stava tracciando
un solco profondo dentro di me scava
traccia due standard se corpi con
disabilità sullo schermo e sulla carta
non ci sono oppure se ci sono nove volte
su dieci la loro vita è descritta come
una tragedia
cosa vuol dire cosa ci dicono tra le
righe con le storie
perché partiamo non è l'esatta
rappresentazione
della realtà è solo una parte quella che
alcune persone scelgono di mostrarci
secondo il club l'organizzazione
americana che si occupa di monitorare la
rappresentazione delle marginalizzazioni
in tv nel 2021 2000 22 la percentuale i
personaggi con disabilità ricorrenti era
solo del 2,8 per cento
questo è un dato americano ma vi
assicuro che anche nel resto del mondo
le cose non sono poi così diverse
per decenni
l'assenza delle persone con disabilità
nelle storie ha insegnato al pubblico
che noi non esistiamo che la nostra vita
non è interessante non è avventurosa lo
porta relazioni lo porta senso la nostra
vita è esclusivamente correlata la cura
ed è questo che io ho introiettato
durante tutta la mia adolescenza per
anni ho finito per guardare me stessa
attraverso il vuoto e la mancanza
la disabilità si manifesta intorno a noi
più spesso di quanto si pensi eppure le
persone entrano anzi el espresse sulla
possibilità di diventare disabili o che
qualcuno intorno a loro lo diventi ne
hanno così paura che spesso dimenticano
che ci sono quasi morto ma molto che
spaventose tipo la partita iva per
esempio
comunque i prodotti intrattenimento
dicono proprio questo alludono a quelle
paure
evitando di affrontare l'argomento o
affrontandolo in maniera obliqua
frammentata per cui nei momenti in cui
la disabilità è presente viene spesso
utilizzata come strumento
melodrammatico delle storie alimentando
gli stereotipi prof.sse credit e il suo
the talk cima manda ancora dice ha detto
e programma degli stereotipi non è tanto
che sono falsi ma che solo incompleti
trasformano una storia e non unica
storia
ecco la vita delle persone con
disabilità è stata ricondotta a
quell'unica storia una storia che
ricalca sempre le stesse caratteristiche
quelle che si sono susseguite ai
mutamenti del concetto di disabilità nel
tempo ora per comprendere quali sono
alcuni di questi stereotipi respira un
po i panni di un alberto angela su ruote
e farò un piccolo excursus storico
l'opinione che la società sa che la
disabilità è cambiata molto nel tempo
spoiler mai in positivo durante il
periodo greco romano ad esempio il corpo
l'aspetto aveva un ruolo cruciale è la
definizione che l'individuo e la
disabilità era considerata una vera e
propria maledizione frutto che l'ira
divina per cui secondo fonti attendibili
storiche tipo i film su sparta le
persone disabili dovevano essere gettati
a per sbaglio giù dalla rupe
capite bene quindi che dà la disabilità
alla malvagità per passo è breve e qui
arriviamo uno stereotipo molto comune
nelle storie di fantasia il villain
ovvero quando la deformità del corpo
rappresenta la deformità dell'anima e le
disabilità fisiche vengono considerati
gli emblemi del male associazione che
ritroviamo in numerosi cattivi con
temporali non ci credete facciamo degli
esempi
darth vader a una serie di cicatrici che
nasconde sotto la maschera nera freddy
krueger al volto schierato tom rider in
harry potter incontra la magia e
lentamente diventa voldemort a cui manca
un lato diversi cattivi in 007 al volto
sfigurato o un arto amputato così come
il joker nel cavaliere oscuro ha due
grandi giocatrici ai lati della bocca
ma andiamo avanti
dopo la caduta dell'impero romano
la chiesa cattolica
acquisisce una forte autorità sociale e
politica e con l'arrivo della
medicalizzazione la chiesa breta
comincia a essere associata alla
tragicità e con la cura all'espiazione
dei peccati insomma anche qui la
maledizione a povero cristo il passo è
breve
e qui arriviamo a un altro stereotipo
molto comune la vittima
cosa hanno in comune il gobbo di notre
dame joseph merrick in viale far man e
tiny tim nel canto di natale
evocano tutti sentimenti di pietà e
compassione diventa lo strumento con cui
le persone possono sentirsi migliori
uscire dal cinema con quel grande
desiderio di altruismo nel cuore per poi
tornare a casa e continuare a insultare
la gente su twitter
pensate sia vera o no cominciava un noto
presentatore e non finisce qui con il
tempo pietà e compassione non spariscono
ma subiscono un evoluzione per xxi
secolo nel 2014
il giornalista e attivista stella young
nel suo talk introduce il concetto di
inspiration porn che no non è un inserto
speciale di penthouse
si tratta della rappresentazione delle
persone con disabilità come fonte di
ispirazione
sulla base proprio per la loro
disabilità
se la pietà nasce dal ritenere la vita
delle persone disabili
ora continua sofferenza
l'altra faccia della medaglia e
considerarli degli eroi sempre comunque
persone meritevoli e stima
incondizionata
applausi come se piovesse complimenti a
non finire preda dietro la porta del
bagno mentre fanno la cacca un po per
supporto è un po per ammirazione
e qui arriviamo a un altro stereotipo
anche questo molto comune il supereroe o
super creep ovvero quando la persona
disabile c e l'afa raggiunge traguardi e
pc
nonostante la sua disabilità questa
modalità narrativa viene utilizzata
spesso in quelle rappresentazioni
cinematografiche
basate su persone disabili realmente
esistite da quelli italiani sono
mangiata o semplificata a uso e consumo
di uno sguardo loan disabile come
avviene ad esempio nel film il mio piede
sinistro dove la vita di christine brown
viene rappresentata con modalità precise
per colpire e ispirare lo spettatore o
cover viene anche in a beautiful mind
nella macchia del tutto in un trofeo per
justin solamente a questi personaggi ed
è anche associato un particolare talento
come avviene ad esempio in forrest gump
che accelera il ping pong o addirittura
un superpotere come vediamo nei fumetti
dove diversi personaggi con disabilità
sono veri e propri supereroi daredevil
professori oracle
avere sempre lo stesso tipo di
rappresentazione dimostra che la
narrazione le nostre storie e spesso
affidata a chi quelle storie con le vive
sulla propria pelle sappiamo bene quanto
l'industria audiovisiva operi
discriminazioni
spesso e volentieri eppure se nel tempo
la rappresentazione che riguarda altre
categoria marginalità che ha trovato
spazio le persone disabili sono nemmeno
rappresentate sullo schermo e la nostra
assenza è riscontrabile sia davanti che
dietro la telecamera
secondo il report e il china garisti
stick uk nel 2021 che si basa su un
sondaggio fatto su
1226 persone che lavorano per la
televisione
93 per cento degli scrittori ha
affermato che le loro team di lavoro non
era presente neanche una persona
disabile
a riprova di questo solo il 2,6 per
cento e gli scrittori ha affermato che
nel loro team di lavoro rappresenti
almeno una persona disabile il ruolo
senior è infatti il 91,7 per cento e gli
scrittori con disabilità intervistati ha
affermato di essere l'unica persona
disabile nella stanza ma vediamo cosa
succede davanti alla telecamera secondo
uno studio del 2016 pubblicato dal
ruderman serve foundation si basa
sull'impiego per le persone con
disabilità nella televisione
nonostante negli stati uniti le persone
disabili siano circa il 20 per cento
della popolazione
il più del 90 per cento dei personaggi
con disabilità e interpretato da attori
e attrici non disabili e infatti anche
nel cinema le cose non sono poi così
diverse
esiste una discriminazione sistemica nei
riguardi di attori e attrici con di
fabbrica che spesso impedisce loro di
arrivare persino ai casting perché di
director di scartare anche per ruoli
scritte apposta per loro
ed ecco quindi che una narrazione e
autentica non può passare sempre e solo
attraverso lo sguardo esterno non può
escludere le persone con disabilità e la
scrittura della produzione dalla
recitazione
i motivi di questa esclusione sono
piuttosto evidenti e all'occhio fare con
potere denaro e privilegio bisogno della
maggioranza bianca è the roaches non
disabile il rivedersi e riconoscersi nei
personaggi sullo schermo spinge alle
case di produzione a rispondere a quei
bisogni per raggiungere grandi numeri
trascurando così la rappresentazione
delle persone marginalizzati proprio
perché non raggiungono quegli stessi
numeri
per poter cambiare le cose è necessario
cominciare a disinnescare la trappola
dell'identificazione
quella che ci porta a scegliere le
storiche ci somigliano trascurando
quelle che sentiamo lontane da noi delle
star e la trappola dell'identificazione
è importante ci serve per allenare
l'esercizio è l'immaginazione e
dell'empatia ci serve per imparare a
godere anche di quei prodotti lontane
dal nostro vissuto
questa è una cosa che le persone con
disabilità hanno imparato a fare sin
dall infanzia proprio perché lui non
incontriamo quasi mai prodotti che ci
appartengono
adesso questo esercizio
spetta a voi è arrivato il momento di
cedere il microfono
dare spazio a chi non lo ha mai avuto
che non significa toglierlo a qualcun
altro ma moltiplicarlo lavorare insieme
affinché ci sia posto per tutti questo
per tutte quelle storie
che non hanno mai visto la luce perché
che non possiamo riconoscerci in quello
che guardiamo leggiamo nelle storie di
fantasia
dovremo sempre la sensazione inconscia
che le nostre vite non siano degne di
essere raccontate
e tempo di cambiare narrazione è tempo
di raccontare la nostra storia
[Musica]